in the late 90s vladimir putin was
promoted to the prime minister of russia
which is basically the second in command
after the actual president
at the time poonam was basically a
nobody to the public
no one knew who he was this was a
problem because he was going to run for
presidents
shortly after four apartment buildings
in moscow and other cities are blown up
with bombs
the bombs exploded in the middle of the
night as people slept hundreds were
killed think of it like a 911 type
events people were scared and needed a
strong leader and then all of a sudden
the prime minister that no one ever
heard of was everywhere swearing revenge
against the terrorists from chechnya he
claimed to be responsible for the
bombings a region in south russia near
georgia
the claims were used to justify a new
invasion of chechnya
and putin's invasion would be brutal
this made putin look like a national
hero conveniently at the same time he
was running for presidents he quickly
became the country's most popular
politician but later on a fifth bomb was
found in an apartment building in a town
called rayazon it was diffused and
inspected for evidence as it turns out
it wasn't placed by chechnyan terrorists
it was most likely placed by agents of
the sfb
the test proved that the bomb contained
an explosive called hexagon that only
the military had access to the bomb's
detonator was also from the military but
it didn't matter in march 2000 vladimir
putin was officially named russia's
president
and now it was finally time for him to
rule and anyone who questioned him or
the origins of the bombing was gonna
face his wrath
today pune has come a long way from his
very humble roots there's a story
vladimir putin likes to tell from his
childhood putin grew up poor and lived
in a communal apartment with two other
families he shared a small room with his
parents all the way up until he was 25
years old his building was pretty run
down it smelled of sweat and boiled
cabbage and to top it all off it was
overrun by rats
since he was a child young vladimir and
his friends made light of the rat
infestation by chasing them around and
tormenting them with sticks
hey buddy yeah what's going on there pal
oh my god i just found a rat's nest
slaughtered about
200 of them
one day putin was messing around with
one of the rats as usual and he had the
rodent backed into a corner with nowhere
to go and that's when it happened the
seemingly helpless rat jumped right at
him to attack putin said the experience
scared him but it also taught him a
valuable lesson if someone is backed
into a corner with nothing left to lose
they're gonna fight back with all they
have it was a lesson putin will remember
for the rest of his life throughout his
career as a kgb spy and as the second
longest running president in europe
today poon's tough upbringing is long in
the past he's one of the most powerful
and allegedly richest people in the
world estimated to personally control 40
billion dollars as of 2014 an amount
that's likely grown a lot since then
meanwhile the average russian citizen's
wealth was barely even 900 around the
same time
this is the rise of one of the most
feared and mysterious men on the planets
[Music]
even though putin is one of the richest
men alive today he started out with
nothing including zero debts
unfortunately for most people that's not
the reality most people are buried in
high interest debt because of things
like credit cards to the point where
they can't even afford to pay off the
interest every month essentially
trapping them in poverty but what if
there was a way to get a loan at a lower
interest rates use that cheaper loan to
pay off the high interest debts so that
you're left with one single monthly
payment with a clear payoff dates well
that's where upstart comes in
upstart is a fast easy way to get a
personal loan online that can help you
pay off your high interest debts whether
you need help paying off credit cards
consolidating high interest debts or
even just to fund some personal expenses
upstart can help by giving you a loan
that requires only one fixed monthly
payment with a clear payoff dates
instead of just looking at your credit
score upstart takes in other factors too
like your income current employment and
credit history to get you a smarter rate
for your loan your loan could be between
one thousand and fifty thousand dollars
plus you can check your rate in minutes
without impacting your credit score once
approved you could get access to your
funds in as little as one business day
if you want to find out how upstart can
lower your monthly payments today go to
upstart.com jake tran that's
upstart.comtran use the link below to
let them know i sent you upstart.comtran
thanks to upstart for sponsoring this
video
[Music]
before vladimir putin was even born he
was influenced by his family's history
his mother maria putina was a factory
worker and his father vladimir
spiridonovich putin served during world
war ii as a part of the soviet navy both
his parents were a product of russia's
instability during the 20th century the
war greatly impacted their family as
vladimir fought away from home maria and
their infant son victor was stuck in the
city conditions were rough both parents
almost died during this time his father
was seriously injured in battle and had
to be carried to a hospital maria
actually passed out on the street one
day and was assumed to be dead her body
was thrown into a pile of frozen corpses
but luckily for her she was discovered
before it was too late because people
heard her moaning while maria and
vladimir both survived against all odds
their son victor didn't he died from an
infection and was buried in a mass grave
with 470 000 other people victor was the
couple's second son to die after their
first son oleg died during infancy after
the war ended their third son was born
vladimir vladimirovich putin born in the
remnants of war and suffering his
parents had no idea that their son would
one day rule mother russia
young vladimir will grow up hearing
stories about the great patriotic war
about his father and country's heroism
and pain and it left a huge impression
on him young vladimir grew up in a
russia that was still suffering from the
effects of the past his family lived in
a 180 square foot apartment with six
other people the apartment had no hot
water and no bathtub it was heated by a
wood burning stove and the toilet was in
the closets outside in the courtyard
shady characters would hang out drinking
and smoking it wasn't much but it was
practically heaven after what the putin
family had endured vladimir was the
family's miracle child he was born when
maria was almost 41 and after having two
sons die the putins were understandably
overprotective of vladimir he didn't
start attending school until he was
almost 8 years old because maria kept
him out of kindergarten people described
young vladimir around this time as an
average student impulsive a bit spoiled
and lagging in the social skills he
might have developed if he started
school earlier and he also wasn't a big
rule follower he was even caught
carrying a knife to school once but
everything changed when vladimir started
taking martial arts he focused on a
soviet martial art called [ __ ] which
combined wrestling in judo vladimir
loved the structure and discipline of
martial arts it completely transformed
his life allowing him to stand up to
bigger kids he said martial arts was
quote a tool to assert myself to the
pack end quotes
his newfound discipline would become a
core part of pune's personality as the
years went on when vladimir was a
teenager an iconic movie called the
shield and the sword came out it was
about a heroic russian spy that
infiltrated the germans in world war ii
and had to become the enemy to fight
them putin was mesmerized by the film
even as an adult decades later he could
still remember the movie's theme song
and that's when vladimir made up his
mind he wasn't going to be a sailor or
pilot he was going to become a spy so
the teenage poon showed up to the kgb
headquarters unannounced and asked how
he could join the officer there told him
that he should study law vladimir took
the advice seriously and went on to
totally reinvent himself he became super
serious about his schoolwork and in 1970
he enrolled in university to study law
in his fourth year of university he was
approached by an undercover kgb officer
and was invited to try out for the kgb
at the age of 22 vladimir putin's dreams
were all coming true he was gonna be a
spy
vladimir putin officially joined the kgb
in 1975 to begin his training the kgb
was a huge bureaucracy that served the
interests of the communist party
searching for enemies within the soviet
union but also abroad vladimir went to
work at his personal office at the kgb's
leningrad headquarters it was the same
building he had visited as a teenager to
ask how to join the kgb putin had come
full circle but he was basically just
doing desk work and continued living in
the same room with his parents
but he worked hard and by 1976 he left
the kgb academy as a first lieutenant
during his career in the kgb putin would
end up wearing a lot of different hats
he started encounter intelligence in his
hometown of leningrad where he monitored
foreigners and the people who worked in
the city's consulates to make sure they
weren't spies
it's okay but it's not the adrenaline
pumping spy work that putin had dreamed
about then in 1979 putin reached the
rank of a captain and was sent to the
kgb's top school in moscow
this is what putin had been waiting for
finally it seemed that they were
preparing him to operate abroad but he
was quickly sent back to leningrad to
monitor foreign interactions again you
see vladimir had a problem he was 28
years old and still unmarried a taboo
for an officer in the kgb
his first chief actually refused to send
unmarried men abroad because he was
worried that they would fall in love
there which would leave them vulnerable
to getting blackmailed and having a wife
back home gives you an incentive to stay
loyal to the cause it was around this
time that vladimir met his eventual wife
he proposed to her in 1983 and for their
honeymoon the couple toured ukraine from
moldova to cremia a place poon later
said was sacred to him from this point
on ukraine will forever hold a special
place in his hearts
one of pun's colleagues named igor
antonov said he believed vladimir got
married to improve his career but hey it
worked he was finally gonna be an
international spy his first foreign
assignment was a small outpost in
germany he was almost 33 years old and
he had never left the soviet union
before the kgb was trying to gather
intel and recruit agents with ties to
the west it was another mission that
sounded intense but putin's role in it
was rather boring for each potential
recruit putin would prepare the
paperwork and then submit it for
approval he was eventually promoted to
deputy chief of the outpost but soon
protests against the german government
started brewing and one day an
anti-communist mob surrendered the kgb
office he was working at putin was told
the kgb couldn't do anything until
moscow ordered it but moscow stayed
silent it was because the soviet union
was dealing with his own turmoil the
soviet union was close to collapsing
this was a turning point for vladimir
putin his career wasn't living up to
expectations his country was going
through turmoil and after 15 years as a
kgb agent he decided it was time to make
a change
[Music]
putin's spy career wasn't going where he
wanted it to so vladimir took a kgb job
at his old university where he was
responsible for watching over students
and campus visitors when he was working
there his superiors ordered him to get a
job with the mayor of saint petersburg
and anatoly subchuk
having an undercover agent working for
the mayor of the second biggest city in
russia was a great plug for the kgb
putin joined the mayor's staff and was
in charge of the city's committee on
foreign relations
but he was still just a guy working in
the shadows in 1991 the soviet union
falls it was the same year that vladimir
putin officially resigned from the kgb
he was busy becoming the mayor's most
indispensable man and he learned a lot
from the notoriously authoritarian
leader who would eventually become his
mentor while he was working there though
he got caught up in his first big
scandal the fall of the soviet union hit
putin's hometown st petersburg hard it
wasn't even enough food to go around
[Music]
so putin and a deputy signed a bunch of
sloppy negotiated contracts that were
supposed to supply the city with enough
food to survive
but the contrast had unusually high
commissions of up to 50 percent and even
worse than that nothing ever showed up
the contractors never delivered any food
124 million dollars disappeared with
nothing to show for it
putin never told the public how the
contractors were selected or even who
they were he just defended himself and
denied it was his faults subject didn't
punish him for the massive blunder or
what other people say as a giant scam
where he stole all the money
instead the mayor promoted putin to the
position of deputy mayor his new
responsibility was attracting foreign
investors into the city it was a role
that vladimir was the perfect fit for
because he spoke german fluently
but it only lasted a little while
subject unexpectedly lost the next
election leaving putin unemployed
his career was beginning to look like it
was headed for another dead end until
the president of russia boris yeltsin
hired him in 1997. putin caught
yeltsin's attention during his work for
the mayor putin was appointed a few
different roles under yeltsin including
the director of the sfb the successor to
the kgb after the fall of the soviet
union then in 1999 yeltsin makes pune
the acting prime minister which is
basically the second in command after
the actual presidents and only a few
months later yeltsin told vladimir that
he wanted him to take over the
presidency that he wanted poon to lead
russia into the new millennium as the
president
it was an unexpected turn of events but
many people believed that yeltsin was
doing it to protect himself
he had done a lot of corrupt stuff
during his presidency and now he was
getting older and weaker he knew he was
going to have to step down eventually
and he wanted to make sure that the next
president wasn't going to go after him
so putin would become president as long
as he could pull through the election
which was going to be kind of difficult
because he was basically unknown to the
public but that's where the apartment
bombings came in that we talked about
earlier
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
after the apartment bombings people were
really suspicious about what went down
and the government's role in it but
putin wasn't going to talk about it in
fact he was willing to take out anyone
who asked too many questions about the
matter in one way or another
mikhail chittesgan was one of the people
who tried to investigate the bombings a
week before he was supposed to release
his findings he was arrested traposkin
was sent to prison for two years when he
was released he tried to speak out about
the apartment bombings again he was
arrested again and put in prison for
another two years
and putin's iron fist didn't just go
after investigators or journalists
and went after anyone who dared question
him
in 2013 mikhail karakovsky was russia's
richest man and an estimated 15 billion
dollars making him the 16th richest
person in the world
one of the most influential men in
russia
that kind of wealth must have gotten to
his head because he thought it gave him
the right to speak up against putin's
corrupt governments putin's response
mikhail was sent to a siberian prison
camp for 10 years and his company along
with his wealth was destroyed
today he lives in exile in switzerland
we have a video coming out on russian
oligarchs next so make sure you
subscribe
the two maquels are still better off
than a lot of other people who made the
mistake of messing with putin
a journalist named anna paula koskaya
was murdered in her apartment lobby in
2006. coincidentally it was right after
she wrote about the russian army's
corruption in chechnya it was very clear
what was going on putin was
consolidating power making sure that no
one dared questioned him he has got so
many guilty secrets so much money's been
stolen so many people have been killed
but he doesn't really trust anyone to
keep him safe if he steps down from par
today putin is 69 years old he's getting
older he's made many enemies his circle
is smaller than ever and he's surrounded
by soldiers 24 7. he's got to be living
in paranoia that maybe his time is
coming maybe he views ukraine as his
last chance to leave some kind of legacy
[Music]
what's up guys we have a few more
russian videos coming out going over
stuff that they're not talking about in
the news so make sure you subscribe so
you don't miss out and also our
feature-length documentary on everyone's
favorite person every jeffstein is out
and you can watch it right now by
clicking the join button below that's
gonna wrap it up stay dangerous out
there and i will see you guys in the
next one
[Music]
you